quartier ville mode au 53 rue denis
papin ce que nous avons juste pas
possible d'assister de telles
dégradations et et que les choses ne
bougent pas des réunions de quartier
avec les locataires
plusieurs lettres courroucée de la
mairie au bailleur social icf atlantique
n'ont pas suffi sais-tu meuble est
désormais considérée comme une verrue et
l'abcès de fixation de tous les
mécontentements ya pas que les façades
moi j'ai aussi des remontées sur la
qualité du logement sur la présence de
punaises sur les présences de cafards
sur et a quand même un travail d'ampleur
à faire y compris sur sur le peuplement
sur les attributions de logements je
crois que notre quartier mérite vraiment
mieux que ça et pour le sorte il faut le
sortir d'affaires malgré des promesses
non tenues du bailleur social
les locataires sont restés et livre
désarroi
on est là depuis 2002 et aérien qui a
été fait avec peinture n'est rien on à
la chambre une fausse chambre dans le
salon du coup un flou et f5 on peut dire
et le niveau du loyer payé environ 700
ça dépend des mois un test plus
d'erreurs emplacement est idéal ya le
tramway à la gale a tout ce qu'il faut
donc je paye environ 500 euros de loyer
donc c'est vrai qu'on m'avait promis
donc en 2007 que la façade allait être
refaite à l'arrêt a été refaite
j'ai eu un problème de fuite l'intérieur
mende au niveau des canalisations qui
commence à être ancienne aujourd'hui
nous on est prêt à lancer le projet il
est validé et herman pour qu'on puisse
le plus vite possible lancer la
réhabilitation des façades mais aussi
des salles de bains dans l'intérieur des
logements des houles et puis intervenir
sur les espaces extérieurs
on est sur un médium pas des millions de
ruches sur la réhabilitation de ce
quartier pour faute de parvenir à un
accord sur la nature et l'ampleur des
travaux la mairie de fleury les aubrais
considère comme une option sérieuse
la reprise de ce dossier par un autre
bailleur social